[Música]
buenas tardes
como se levantaron hoy
yo me levanté travesti
si me levanté travesti no no le pasa a
ustedes es a veces
da un poco de escozor la palabra bueno
vamos a decirlo así nos liberamos un
poco yo digo 123 y decimos todo es
travesti 123 travesti no más fuerte
1-2-3 travesti muy bien ahora si puede
hablarle a través de este y bueno
algunos dirán esta me suena que viene a
hablarnos de lo mal que la pasó en la
prostitución no soy del 4% de las
mujeres trans que pueden elegir de qué
medio pueden subsistir
algunos preguntara hay capas que viene a
hacernos un show cómico con su identidad
de género tampoco eso se lo dejo al y sí
que la respeto y la quiero mucho
no hay más opciones abogada arquitecta
no claro travesti puede ser o cómica o
prostituta o no peluquera bueno traiga
menos tijera en la cabeza pero el
desastre que voy a hacer va a ser
tremendo
bueno porque digo que me levanté otra
vez este hoy y porque es parte de mi
identidad es la identidad que me dio la
sociedad la identidad que me diste vos
cuando me viste por la calle
esa mamá o ese papa que van por el subte
y se codea con el niño adelante diciendo
mira el travesti
el magazine de la noche que titula el
bosque de los travestis y la
prostitución y la gente asocia
automáticamente una palabra con la otra
este diario nacional que dice la
ideología de género de los travestis
pervierte a nuestros niños y la madre
joven entra en pánico y piensa que un
travesti este en el barrio es horrible
o esos mediáticos ignorantes que dicen
flor del ave es un hombre y transmiten
la transfobia y la violencia a la
sociedad
todas estas personas crecieron en la
indiferencia en esta mala educación de
la violencia contra las personas trans y
el día de mañana ustedes
se van a cruzar con una persona trans y
no van a tener más información que toda
esta horrible información que circunda
en los medios de comunicación en los
medios de comunicación
y
[Música]
si yo aquí podría mentirles podría
decirles que mis padres tuvieron esta
ideología anti género que les generó la
sociedad y los medios y que por eso me
trataron como un raro cuando yo
tenía 7 años y que por eso me tuve que
ir de mi casa y que mi abuelo tenía una
ideología anti género y que por eso le
dijo a mi viejo cuando yo tenía 7 años
que era un mariposón
pero
no es eso no es una ideología anti
genera mis padres veían a su hija trans
y no sabían qué hacer tenían miedo y
sentían el peor destino con toda esta
mala información que tenían nadie les
enseño a mis padres que un niño o una
niña puede elegir a quien se quiere
parecer es lo más sano que le puede
pasar en la vida acaso ustedes no fueron
libres de elegir a quien se querían
parecer
yo aquí les podría mentir también que un
jefe que tuve hace ocho años
me dijo que me dijo hasta que no traigas
un dni que dice mujeres yo te voy a
seguir tratando como hombre
yo podría mentirles que él tenía una
ideología anti género
podría mentirles que las discotecas de
buenos aires tienen una ideología anti
género o la tenían cuando me dejaron
entrar porque mi dni no condecía con mí
con mi apariencia
podría hablarles de un montón de
situaciones que me hicieron mucho daño a
causa de esta mala información de esta
mala educación que tuvimos durante
tantos años que algo cambió con la la
identidad de género pero que todavía
falta
lograr un poco de cambio
que me hicieron daño porque
transformaron esta palabra esta palabra
que los incómodo tanto cuando yo entré a
este escenario que la transformaron en
un insulto
pero esto no se trata de ideología anti
género
esto se trata de ignorancia de falta de
información de una sociedad que se ha
educado como pudo
pero hoy en día sabemos que nuestra
sociedad puede cambiar y que la sociedad
es lo que nosotros hacemos de ella
yo realmente sentí mucho daño
cuando vi que tenía el amor de mis
padres y el amor de mi abuelo y de un
día para otro se convirtió en vergüenza
y me pedían que me oculte por ser como
soy
pero en la contracara de todo esto por
suerte la vida me regaló a alguien muy
importante
que se llama alexis vino a 16 años
después de terminar cimiento y es mi
hermano
yo hasta sus siete años no me animaba a
salir a mostrarme con mi identidad de
mujer delante de él por miedo a que
malinterprete por prejuicios sociales
sobre todo de mi familia o conmigo misma
y un día
sin haberme visto jamás con mi identidad
de mujer él sabía que yo iba a salir con
mis amigas esa noche y se acercó y me
dijo esta noche otra vez te convertiste
en victoria me bautiza victoria
mi madre y yo quedamos heladas
no podíamos creer que un niño de 7 años
nos estaba enseñando la hermosa libertad
de poder elegir quién queremos ser y me
enseñó que yo no me iba a ir al infierno
por ser quien yo quería ser y que yo
sentía hacer
este niño ya es un hombre futuro
profesor de educación física tuvo hace
poco una entrevista de trabajo y me
preguntaba algunos tips para presentarse
por suerte quedo
jamás se le ocurriría jamás se le
ocurriría que una persona por ser trans
es prostituta porque creció con su
hermana que le enseñó que las personas
trans podemos elegir otra forma de vida
porque tenemos las mismas capacidades
que cualquier persona aunque este estado
todavía nos lleva a la ley de cupo
laboral trans para sacarnos de la calle
del resto de las 96 % que siguen en
prostitución
a mi hermano jamás se le ocurriría
discriminar a una persona por su
identidad de género por ser diferente
en la calle hay mucho violento pero él
creció conmigo él creció sabiendo que
eso no era motivo para violentar a nadie
de todas maneras en la escuela si te
enseñan a no matar
por ende todos esos violentos que se
llevaron la vida de mis compañeras
merecen el castigo de la justicia como
cualquier criminal porque por culpa de
esta violencia tenemos una expectativa
de vida de solamente 35 años
ustedes alguna vez tuvieron que calcular
su expectativa de vida por ser quienes
son
pero que no
sueño con un mundo lleno de niños como
mi hermano
niños que sepan que cambiar de género es
solamente eso
es ser una persona trans o transgénero o
travesti o como se quiera llamar quien
duda
acaso que enseñarles a los niños y niñas
a respetar a las personas por su
identidad les puede hacer bien quien
duda de eso quien duda de que a mis
padres si a mis padres lo hubieran
enseñado cómo tratar a una niña trans yo
hubiera podido ser una niña más feliz
quien duda que educarnos en la igualdad
y en el respeto al otro puede hacer una
sociedad peor
es ilógico
el respeto al otro es lo que se debería
enseñar en todas las escuelas en todas
las familias
yo no vengo aquí a hablar
solamente de mi historia vengo a
hablarles de identidad de género vengo a
hablarles de ser quien unos sueños ser
siempre y que nadie tenga derecho a
juzgarte por eso y nosotras las personas
trans no tenemos voz entonces yo vengo a
pedirles que ustedes sean nuestras voces
que ustedes en el día de hoy no me
aplaudan no quiero su aplauso sería
hermoso escucharlo pero realmente
prefiero otra cosa prefiero que en este
momento abran sus teléfonos celulares
hay un tiempo
y elijan a una persona de su familia a
quien le quieran enviar este mensaje un
hermano un hijo el grupo de la familia
alguien de trabajo solamente
esta frase
hablemos de las personas trans
conviertan en un hashtag ayúdanos a
hablar de nosotras porque nosotras no
tenemos voz necesitamos que en la calle
que las escuelas que en las familias se
hablen de nosotros se hable de la
identidad del género
para que el día de mañana en el subte
en la calle en la familia lo raro no sea
la palabra travesti
si no esa persona que mira raro cuando
alguien pronuncia esa hermosa palabra
que significa hacer de la identidad lo
que cada uno quiera muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]